fans are eagerly awaiting tom cruise
kicking the tires and lighting the fires
in the long-awaited sequel top gun
maverick but what does this top gun
co-star think about the follow-up did
she and cruz get along keep watching to
find out
cruz is indisputably one of hollywood's
biggest stars and at times a polarizing
figure due to his personal life his
performance as daredevil navy aviator
pete maverick mitchell in 1986's top gun
is what shot him to the top of the pack
in top gun maverick cruz is poised to
return to the naval fighter weapons
school as an instructor who will train
the latest crop of hotshot pilots kelly
mcgillis who played charlotte charlie
blackwood in the original film revealed
to entertainment tonight in 2019 that
she wasn't asked to reprise her role in
the top gun sequel i just want to manage
expectations
instead cruz's character has a new lady
in his life penny benjamin played by
jennifer connelly according to cinema
cinemablend benjamin owns a bar near the
famous flight school and is a pilot of a
different kind
i'm a sailor i used to race boats and
film and give you that
due to some high-profile off-screen
hijinks and a long association with the
controversial church of scientology tom
cruise had earned a bit of a mixed
public reputation with that in mind you
might expect that his on-set behavior
matches his eccentric tabloid headlines
but when it comes to cruz mcgillis has
only nice things to say about her former
on-screen love interest and what he was
like on the set of the 1986 film
confirming our long-held belief that
cruz might be a little more down to
earth than his reputation suggests in a
2013 interview with the los angeles
times kelly mcgillis recalled that
except for tom cruise and vel kilmer the
top gun cast stayed at the same hotel
during the shoot and had a lot of time
to bond she told the outlet tom cruise
was incredibly respectful polite and
very honest there was definitely a big
ensemble group camaraderie similarly she
had nothing but good things to say about
the actor in a 2013 interview with yahoo
movies saying i think tom is terrific
he's the sweetest guy he is very genuine
and sincere and respectful and i just
loved working with tom i think he is
wonderful although the upcoming sequel
has thrust mcgillis back into the
spotlight the actress doesn't appear
much interested in fame these days in
2019 mcgillis told et to me my
relationships to other people became far
more important than my relationship to
fame mcgillis also admitted that she
hasn't kept in touch with her former
co-stars and at the time she hadn't seen
the trailer for top gun maverick and
appeared somewhat ambivalent about
watching the finished product notably
jennifer connolly appears to share her
predecessor's high opinion of cruz
particularly when it comes to his
professionalism and unparalleled work
ethic on set connolly told cinemablend
in 2020 i've never seen anyone work
harder be more committed to his work
every moment is an opportunity to do all
that he can do to deliver the best thing
that he can possibly deliver in addition
to enjoying her time working alongside
tom cruise mcgillis told yahoo movies
that the entire top gun cast was close
she recalled that after shooting they
would throw parties and play sports to
unwind mcgillis went on to say that it
was like being at a summer camp where
everyone worked together and played
together afterward in 2019 she told et
that movies create unique relationships
because they bring people so close for
brief moments in their lives saying i
think i've spoken to a couple of people
occasionally but the truth is movies are
very odd work situations because you
have a lot of people who come together
from all different parts of the world
despite her positive memories of being
on set and her appreciation for the
life-changing role mcgillis has been
honest about why she wasn't brought back
for a sequel back in 2013 she speculated
that she wouldn't be invited back
because of her age and appearance she
told the los angeles times you hear
women of my age talk about this all the
time i think this industry is not
particularly kind to women who are over
50. i am not into the coloring of my
hair doing the botox and getting a
facelift while she isn't involved with
the upcoming sequel mcgillis told et
that she's happy for connolly to have
the part top gun maverick hits theaters
on may 27th check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff for
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]